so you had the privilege of what two
weeks rehearsal with your four actors
here in your kitchen in the kitchen
mm-hmm okay so from the rehearsals to in
your kitchen to being on set you know
what was it like working with the four
of them and what type of direction were
you giving them how hands-on were you
how much did you just kind of lean back
and just let them do their thing well
again this goes back to the oven advice
you know ninety percent of directing is
casting and and since I couldn't use a
Harold Ramis advice of getting Bill
Murray other actors had to go with the
almond advice but now I mean these were
terrific actors and David Harbor
especially knew the script backwards and
forwards or at least he knew the play
and you know obviously changes but um
but they were all just great actors and
so you kind of try not to screw it up
you know is the main thing but um but
with rehearsal there was you know the
real specific intention in the in the
original play and then you know and I
like to play because it had so much
dialogue it was very quick dialogue and
we wanted to do it we wanted quick
overlapping dialogue intentionally and
so a lot of it was just kind of running
the lines you know just getting them you
know they didn't have to be completely
off book for the whole movie but just
getting that familiarity with with the
script and with each other but a lot of
it was was also just that chemistry
among themselves and as it turned out
pretty much all of them at one point or
another we're all staying in the same
hotel at the redbury hotel where we were
also filming so even when we weren't
having formal rehearsal here we would do
rehearsals there they would get together
on their own and Julie and Melissa would
run scenes together just on their own
you know and just kind of develop this
report cuz they're all supposed to be
old friends so they may as well start
acting like friends you know and so I
think that really helped as much as
running the lines themselves just being
around each other i think really lent
a lot of familiarity among among the
four of them and with me as well and but
also a lot of times you get in
situations on set where an actor will
say now what about this one word what
does this mean or someone will say oh
wait a minute didn't we just use that
word and something out you know but you
get in these long digressions like let's
talk about this let's talk about the
meaning of this and it can put
everything you know you can have a halt
for an hour on set but if you're doing
that in rehearsal you got all the time
in the world you don't have 50 people
standing around you with cameras and
lights that you're renting so we would
take our time with her rehearsals and
say okay well let's talk about this and
and it was great we had Joe the
playwright johor tua was there for most
of the rehearsal time so people could
say okay what in the original play how
was it here and what was the original
intention with this character and this
line and we could you know kind of
improvise some some slight changes and
do little rewrites you know Joe and I
would kind of confer at the end of each
day rehearsal and work with the our
script supervisor was there for a
rehearsal so anytime we can make we made
a tweak and then by the time the
rehearsal period ended we actually
printed out a whole new script now then
that was the script so it was really
helpful I think in a lot of ways yeah
and I understand bringing together
people and having them develop good
chemistry what about the tension because
there was tension filled scenes in there
that were very realistic how did you
create that there was animosity there
was jealousy you could see it on their
faces how did you make that work a lot
of that was real okay it was um uh yeah
i mean i like to say like normally when
you're making a three-week shoot you
know the first week everyone's excited
and happy to be the second week well
we're getting over the hump in the third
week eh we're almost done this was a lot
longer because we had you know this day
in the snow and then three weeks later
we started two weeks rehearsal within
that two-week rehearsal time we did a
whole one day of photo shooting at the
mole richardson stage with still photos
so all the background still images
because the characters are photographers
are in the
they're so which was almost like a dry
run on production and then you know and
then we had three weeks of principal
photography and then three weeks later I
went to Nebraska for a week in shop for
a day and a half and then went to New
York for another week and shop for a day
and a half there so for me it was like
four months but yeah so by the time you
start shooting it's not really the first
day of production it's like Oh anyway
we're just starting now you know any
drama you know with the cast and crew
you know has already started so and
you're like oh and now we're starting
you know so now we have three weeks so
it was really psychologically it's more
like a five-week shoot you know event if
anything I think I you know that was
interesting dealing with that but um but
now but these were just great actors and
you know and they all had different
acting styles you know some were method
and some were not and some were not
trying to be method but because the
things going on their own lives things
came out you know I think all of them
tapped into you know some real deep
feelings you know I mean he can't be
that good and I'm out tap into that
stuff and it comes out you know I think
it's you know this the screenplay is
that you know the stories about these
photographers and sacrificing artistic
integrity for a paycheck and you know
actors and filmmakers that's our lives
too you know so so it was definitely
some real emotions that they can all tap
into yeah then they pulled it off and
there was a little bit of sort of class
struggle or class yeah you know some
people feeling may be embarrassed about
certain things that they had and and you
could sense resentment from certain
characters that didn't and I just
thought it was great the way you you had
that shown there the tension between
them so i was just wondering how you get
people that are friendly amongst each
other and things are going well and you
get that that tension in the background
and yeah I don't know they're just you
know good actor sir are good at that and
I think they they love this material
I love these characters I mean part of
it I think also helped that we shot it
in chronological sequence which is to
say we shot out like the play which was
the whole we shot the scenes in the
house midwestern house six days in a
house in order and then we shot the
scenes in the New York apartment in
order so when they're saying things in
the New York apartment like oh we're so
sorry about what happened and we're
sorry about what happened here and oh
that thing that happened that night we
all know and they all know as actors
what did happen because we shot it
already and we're not going back to that
so whatever it is i think that was
helpful especially in this in in
something that structurally is goes back
and forth back and forth at least for
the actors it went very chronologically
and I think for them was very helpful so
it was real it really happened yeah yeah
you